supongamos que tengo la función gdx g de
x es igual a 9 por 8 elevado a la
potencia x menos 1 así que la x está
aquí en el exponente y esto está
definido para
para x un entero un entero
positivo
positivo así que esta función está
definida para 1 2 3 4 5 6 así y bueno
entonces lo que quiero hacer es dar una
expresión recursiva para esta función
dada de modo explícito lo primero que
voy a hacer es una pequeña tabla para
ver cómo se comporta gx así que déjenme
hago una tabla aquí vamos a poner
de este lado vamos a poner x donde x va
a ser esta x acá va a tomar el mismo
valor y es 9 x 8 x x 1 y acá vamos a
poner cuánto vale de x cuánto vale la
función en x bien como x tiene que ser
un entero vamos a probar con digamos 1 2
3 4 también 1 2 3 4 y bien cuando x vale
1 cuanto al eje x pues cuando x vale 1
gdx sería 9 x 8 a la 1 - 18 a la 0 que
es lo mismo que 9 x 180 es 19 por 1 que
es 9
y cuando x vale 2 que pasa cuando x vale
2 tengo 9 por 8 a la 2 menos uno que es
8 a la 1 que es 8 así que tengo 9 x
8 9 por 8 y cuando x vale 3 ahora
tendría 9 por 8 a la 3 - 1 así que es 9
por 8 al cuadrado que es lo mismo que 9
por 8 por 8 y cuando x vale 4 cuánto
vale gdx pues vale 9 por 8 a la 4 menos
uno que es al cubo es decir 9 por 8 por
8 por 8 y creo que ustedes ya ven aquí
un patrón
creo que ya ven un patrón cada término
aquí se obtiene multiplicando el término
anterior por 8 esto es lo mismo que 9
por 8 por 8
y esto es lo mismo que 9 por 8 por 8 por
8 así que vamos a definir nuestra
función de manera recursiva voy a
definir gx de modo recursivo y primero
siempre que tengan algo recursivo
necesitan el caso base cuánto vale la
función en el primer momento y ese caso
base es este de aquí la función cuando x
vale 1 vale 9 así que voy a definir la
función g x como 9
si x es igual a 1 y acá pues el término
en cualquier momento es igual al término
anterior por 8 es decir imagínense que
aquí continuará hasta llegar hasta x
menos 1 y después a x ok y entonces
cuánto vale la función acá pues no sé
pero vale g de x 1 de hecho yo sé que
quede x menos 1 es 9 por 8 a la x menos
2 x 1 - 1 que sería x menos 2 y cuánto
valen aquí la función pues por un lado
tiene que valer de x pero gtx es 9 por 8
por x al menos 1 pero eso lo voy a
escribir como x a la menos 2 x 8
así que de nuevo este término de x lo
tuve como eje x 1 por 8 así que voy a
definir acá la función como
gd x 1
por 8 si x
es un entero
mayor que uno mayor uy mayor que 1
bien vamos a comparar las dos funciones
para ver que estamos bien
voy a hacer otra tabla por aquí
y otra tabla
de nuevo voy a comparar el valor de x
contra el valor de g de x pero ahora voy
a usar la definición recursiva de eje x
así que lo voy a hacer con este azul
aquí pongo x que va a valer 1234
etcétera podría continuar y aquí voy a
poner gdx cuando x vale 1 por definición
la función g definida recursiva mente de
este modo vale 9 cuando x vale 19 x vale
9 cuando x vale 2
entonces obtendría que g de 2
es igual a por definición porque 12 es
un entero mayor que 1
tengo que g de 2 es igual a g de dos
menos uno por ocho pero cuánto es que de
2 - 1
eso es gd 1 x 80 g de 1969 así que esto
vale 9 por 8 noten como necesite saber
cuánto valía la función un espacio antes
vamos a ver ahora g de 3 cuanto al eje
de 3 pues g de 3 va a ser igual a
gd 3 - 13 menos 1 por 8 eso es lo que me
dice la definición de nuevo 3 es un
entero mayor que 1 así que esto cuánto
es 3 - 1 es 2 así que esto es g de 2 por
8 pero cuánto es que de 2 aquí lo tengo
es 9 por 8 así que de 3 es 9 por 8 por 8
en este caso aquí es precisamente g de
dos así que noten que me va dando los
mismos valores que de 1 es 9 en ambos
casos g de 12 9 por 8 en ambos casos y
gt3 es 9 por 8 por 8 en ambos casos así
que esta es la definición recursiva de
esta función definida explícitamente